the latest economic data have come in
stronger than expected which suggests
that the ultimate level of interest
rates is likely to be higher than
previously anticipated restoring price
stability will likely require that we
maintain restrictive stance of monetary
policy for some time the historical
record cautions strongly against
prematurely loosening policy we will
stay the course until the job is done
that is Fed chair Jerome Powell warning
the FED could raise interest rates
higher later this month to curb
inflation this will make everything
Americans buy with credit even more
expensive Powell also telling Senators
yesterday the rate hikes could come at a
more frequent pace and that the
president's fiscal policies are not to
blame for the surge in prices and of
course you can bet he got an earful from
both sides
if you could stick directly to the 2
million hard-working people who have
decent jobs today who you're planning to
get fired over the next year what would
you say to them inflation is extremely
high and it's hurting the working people
of this country badly all of them not
just two million of them and
putting two million people out of work
is just part of the cost and they just
have to bear it you're raising interest
rates to slow the economy are you not
yes to cool the economy off so in effect
this I'm not being critical
when you're slowing the economy you're
trying to put people out of work that's
your job is it not
really we're trying to we're trying to
restore price stability
Republican senator John Kennedy of
Louisiana a member of the Senate banking
Appropriations and Judiciary committees
joins me now
um excellent questioning uh I don't know
if you really got the answers you were
looking for because I don't think that
they understand the recipe for disaster
that it would actually be if the Federal
Reserve were not only to raise interest
rates higher and faster than expected to
combat inflation but this is just the
beginning they plan there's going to be
like a long line of rate hikes to come
well chairman Powell is just doing his
job look President Biden persists in
saying
that my words not his a honey bun costs
20 bucks and your 401k is crashing
because the economy is so good
No One Believes that because it's not
true and the American people aren't
stupid
President Biden's inflation is
pernicious it is a cancer on the
American dream
and we're not going to get it down
without
costing millions of people their jobs
unless Congress helps on the fiscal Side
by reducing the rate of growth of
spending
and reducing the rate of growth of debt
accumulation and Jay Powell knows that
he can't say it and anyone who knows a
an economic economics textbook from an
LL Bean catalog knows that all right all
right Senator Kennedy if you could stand
by just a moment the house select
subcommittee on the coronavirus pandemic
is meeting right now trying to determine
the covid origins Jim Jordan was
questioning let's go to that real quick
Dr Raptor you were you're uh you you ran
the CDC and you were on the coronavirus
task force is that right correct that
was formed on January 29th 2020 is that
right correct two days later Dr fauci
gets an email from Dr Anderson which
says what virus looks engineered virus
not consistent with evolutionary theory
is that accurate
that's my understanding the next day I
know did he share that email with you by
the way Dr Redfield no as a member of
the task force as a head of CDC did he
share that email with you
profounce you another email that email
says I don't know how this happens in
nature but it would be easy to do in a
lab did you share that email with your
doctor right you didn't see either one
of those emails even though your head of
CDC even though you're on the
coronavirus task force that have been
formed just two days three days earlier
no three days later Dr Anderson and Dr
Gary who told us it came from the lab
and emails to Dr fauci that Dr fauci
wouldn't let Dr Redfield see three days
later they changed their position
180 degrees
the question is why
Mr Wade why would they change their
position that fast when the only
intervening event is a conference call
with Dr fauci the guy who wouldn't let
Dr Redfield see the very emails that
they had sent him Dr Redfield head of
CDC on the chronovirus task force why
would they change their position Dr way
or Mr Wade
well this question does lie at the
hearts of the issue
what is pertinent it seems to me is
there's there's no new scientific
evidence that we can see that came
available in between these dates the
January 1st and Feb four right there's
no new I think you're go ahead so you
have to ask if there were other other
kinds of influence available oh no it is
true that that um
and Dr fauci and Dr ferry in London were
very powerful research officials and
between them I read your testimony I saw
that yeah so why don't you cut to the
Chase and tell them what you really
think was the reason I didn't know what
the reason was I know what it was I but
no go ahead go ahead I'll let you say
because I read your testimony I think
you you said it in your testimony too
maybe relax and say it here but go ahead
well if you're looking at the timeline
on May 21st
um just a few weeks after the nation met
the the nation medicine I was going to
come out
two of the signatures of the original
email to Dr fauci that that's Dr
Anderson and Dr Gary were awarded a 9
million dollar grant for them so there's
nine million reasons why they changed
their mind I knew you'd get to it I read
that last night
three months after
so three days after they say it came
from a lab they changed their position
in the only intervening events a
conference call with Dr fauci and Dr
Collins again a call that Mr Redfield
was not allowed to be on the head of CDC
and on the coronavirus task force and
then three months later Shazam they get
9 million bucks from Dr fauci
well I didn't act something isn't that
something that's why we want to talk to
these guys that's why chairman winstrom
wants to bring in Dr Anderson and Dr
Gary and ask them a series of questions
so we can get to the bottom of this so
we can move forward and deal with this
here's the key question like I don't I'm
not I'm just a common sense guy from
Ohio my I well I was I majored in
wrestling in college but I got a degree
in economics you're supposed to get a
degree when you go to college I got one
in economics and one of the things they
tell you about is a thing called
opportunity cost so when you're spending
your time making sure that the country
believes only one of these theories
you could have been doing what Dr
Redfield was doing in our government
trying to figure out how we deal with
this virus and what was what was Dr
fauci doing he was trying to cover his
backside and everybody knows it and
that's the part that ticks us up because
this is the highest paid guy in our
government getting all kinds of money to
tell us things that were not accurate
because we now know U.S tax dollars went
to a lab in China a lab that was not up
to code a lab that was doing gain of
function research and that's where this
thing most definitely came from and Dr
fauci had to prove no no he can't have
that news getting out and that's why he
did what he did to the exclusion of a
brilliant guy running our CDC kept him
out of the loop keeping him out of the
loop probably potentially could have
harmed America
that's the thing that ticks us all off
and that's why Mr chairman this this
hearing is so darn important and we get
to the bottom of really what happened I
yield back
thank you at this point I'm going to
make a closing wow all right well let's
talk about it Senator Kennedy you got to
weigh in on this uh this is the house
select subcommittee uh on the
coronavirus pandemic uh there you just
listened to Congressman Jim Jordan
firing away questions to which he knows
the answer right I mean he knows that
there are lies behind this
Administration he knows that fauci knew
more than what he admits to and he just
wants to see accountability as should
the rest of us we after three years
millions of deaths should know the
origins of covid and it took for the
house to be run by Republicans to
finally get to the bottom of it or at
least try to
well sunlight is an extraordinarily
effective
antiseptic look I know Dr fauci he's a
smart man
he has a silver tongue
he enjoys doing media interviews
but his behavior
and lack of Candor during the the
epidemic
has um undermined almost immeasurably
the institution of Science and Public
Health
and no one knows who to believe anymore
and I think it's incumbent on Dr fauci
and his colleagues who participated with
him
to go in front of the American people
and and tell them the truth and tell
them why they said what they said in in
light of the evidence that they had that
they did not share with the American
people
and this that's not a political
statement that's a fact people need to
believe in science people need to
believe in public health
and when you've been through what we've
been through I just think Dr fauci and
his team have hurt both
yeah it's a shame but we do deserve
answers especially for all those people
who lost loved ones they deserve answers
um there are a couple hearings that
we're watching right now in Washington
right now the Senate is also uh in the
middle of holding a hearing on worldwide
threats with China uh playing a big role
obviously you know a lot about this
hearing as well today's hearing coming a
day after China's foreign minister took
a direct shot at the U.S saying ties
between both Nations uh risk going off
the rails he even warned that current
U.S strategy risks plunging the Nations
into a conflict you've got Chinese
leader Xing ping Xi Jinping unleashing
similar verbal Salvo at Washington the
White House meantime brushing off the
Hostile language watch
we seek a strategic competition with
China we do not seek conflict there's
been no change to our One China policy
we don't believe that the Chinese have
taken that
option off their table of lethal
assistance but we also haven't seen any
indications that they've acted on it and
it should not be in China's interest to
want to do that of course it's not in
China's interest to want to do that but
when is it in China's interest to do
anything stupid that they do and what
deterrent is there from this
Administration to stop them from doing
so
China is wealthy in part because of the
United States we helped China be
admitted to the World Trade Organization
on December 11 2001.
China started cheating December 12th for
a long time we put up with it president
XI has been president of China since
2013 and he's been very very aggressive
all over the world
I do not want a cold war with China I do
not want a hot war with China all I want
from China is for China to be a
responsible member of a stable world
order but that's up to China
and president XI it is a parent
only understands strength
appeasing him is like trying to hand
feed a shark
now having said all that Julie that
doesn't mean we shouldn't talk we do
need to talk we need to talk with China
about trade about nuclear proliferation
about the South China Sea about Taiwan
I'll let me say it again I don't want a
hot or cold war with China but a lot of
that's up to China with President XI
if you turn the other cheek
you'll just get it in the neck
he under he understands strength and we
have to be firm but open to improving
the relationship yeah we need to be show
more strength okay he's going to come at
us with strength you got to go beyond
that I mean that's just the bottom line
when President what was one of the first
things that President bid did when he
became president he got rid of the China
initiative at the Department of Justice
whereby we were putting College
professors in jail for selling their
research to China right President Biden
got rid of it what kind of message did
that send to president XI weakness
weakness yeah all right uh loved having
you on thank you so much for hanging out
with us as well and just and being so
patient Senator John Kennedy it's always
great to talk to you thank you thank you
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis